Twitter cracks and crumbles at our feet
as the man behind Tonya McGrath Andrew
Doyle joins me online and wisdom let's
say that someone hasn't seen the
Tattaglia account how would you describe
it I would describe it as a kind of
social justice activist who is very
humorless is desperate to be offended
desperate to promote our own victimhood
and is not necessarily stupid but is
swallowed this ideology to the extent
that they is stopping em to think for
themselves questions for titania how
would she answer let's see how we get
all right number one are all cats
feminists which is the most oppressive
vegetable is that when Little Mix
tweeted about the bombing of Syria they
sent an apology saying - I was so sorry
to the people of Syria but the people of
Syria were thinking great at least
Little Mix have got our back look I'm
not saying these people who shouldn't
have the right to have an opinion of
course they do but I don't give a [ __ ]
what Little Mix think about Syria we are
living in a culture where people are
self censoring out of fear of either
what your peers will say what the people
on social media are gonna do to you you
know in the UK we have a horrible
situation where we have hate speech laws
that have led to people being imprisoned
for jokes they've written on Facebook
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
twitter cracks and crumbles at our feet
as the man behind titania mcgrath andrew
Doyle joins me on lot of wisdom Andrew
welcome to show such a dramatic opening
I know it's almost apocalyptic I like it
it's kind of appropriate though right uh
well I don't know like a deus ex machina
have so it descended from the heaven
that's exactly why you're here yeah I've
got the Train it's not a fuzz exciting
yeah like a phoenix from the ashes yeah
so how have you been the last few weeks
I'm all right I'm just a bit nakid
because I was out with a friend late
last night really late
yeah but early functioning I'm all right
yeah it was over from Sweden so didn't
have a choice that's insane
but yeah I'm yeah I'm good but I've been
all over the place I've been back and
forth cosplayer I'm not good traveler I
get really tired so okay I'm just yeah
so I'm a bit frazzled
that's why totally fine and that's good
because that means anything I say that's
inappropriate I can blame on my
condition yeah yeah whatever Caitlin so
your fringing Plus London and musing and
tweeting and doing all this sort of
stuff at the moment yes I've got the
Tanya McGrath Trevor's on at during the
fringe at the moment but I'm not the end
most of the time but I've got my own
stand-up show which starts on Monday
right and you've got to look after
yourself and look after her and then
somehow look after your online personas
as well yeah sort of juggling a few
things it's like we're all busy
everyone's business
not everyone's quite as busy as you so
can you explain why were sat here
talking about a fictional female
character and you juggling Twitter
accounts um because you invited me which
is very nice but also because in other
words how I ended up doing this as a job
yeah I asked myself that question I
started the character last year last
April so sort of about 15 months ago or
something and more just for my own
entertainment
and I wanted to sort of annoy some
people on Twitter basically and it
without it being you without it being me
yeah I I was interested I love I love
the idea of inhabiting a persona I
always like being behind someone else
I know even with the stand-up I do it's
a character really it's not really me so
I like the idea of that distance that
you get but I also thought I was a big
fan of like the satirical accounts on
Twitter that either the personas you
know people like the Godfrey Alec
account and things like that I was
really into the I thought I do myself
and I spoke to Lisa graves who co-wrote
the Godfrey Africa countess she's based
quite near she's based in Hull actually
okay and I spoke to her about her work
with the Godfrey awkward thing and I
said I you know I've always wanted to do
this and she said you should just do it
and encouraged me to do it
Shivam created the picture for me
through yeah and and then so I just I
just went with it when did you start
become April
yeah April this year last year - yeah
and then and then she got banned so
often early on like my whole point of it
was that I was just goodbye first I
decided she was gonna be a slam poet she
was going to be intersectional feminist
all of that stuff she's gonna be
massively contradictory but just
completely offended by absolutely
everything really privilege really
obviously privilege but not recognizing
her and privilege because you wanted to
be a victim so all the kind of stuff
that we recognized and then I also made
that decision early on I wasn't going to
self-censor
at all I think one of the real problems
with comedy at the moment is people are
hedging their bets they're worried about
what they're saying because they want to
be successful that makes complete sense
I thought well I'm not no one knows this
is me I can say anything some of the
early tweets were really vile actually
just just sometimes just provocative for
its own sake yeah and you won't see them
anymore because that to delete them all
no but what would happen is I get this I
got a couple of one day bands then I got
a seven day ban and I got another seven
day ban and I thought well you know the
and then at one point he must have been
around September something like I don't
know Joker permanent ban so Twitter said
the email saying work permanently
suspended you can't come back and then
there's a big uproar on Twitter all
these sort of prominent people
complaining to Twitter yeah and then
Twitter brought it back again because
there's a provision on Twitter
or satirical account yes or as I had
protection kind of thing as long as you
as long as it's apparent that it is yeah
you can kind of get away with more right
so their rule is if you if you've got a
parody account which is a specific
mocking of another person you have to
put parody in your buyer okay this isn't
a parody account - satire account i'm
not i'm not parroting a particular
person okay yeah that's interesting so
i'm in people often don't understand
that difference in setting priorities so
it's a different thing
i'm but there is provision that twitter
ostensibly and their rules say that's
okay you should be allowed to do that
but they found some of the language and
some of the imagery i suppose a bit
unpleasant and then completely bounder
all they took it literally i don't know
can you remember what the tweet was that
was the full bar what the full ban was
I've been she was saying that she was
going to a you Kipp March to punch
people in the name of tolerance and that
was all it was
and I imagine that was probably just
insight into violence maybe I guess so
yeah didn't you incite violence against
yourself last night yeah I did are you
following me on Twitter thing is it Wow
yeah I did cuz I I comment what I did
now I was drunk
what was it so I'll tell you okay the
tatanya account retweeted your show fire
at the end said this imposter is doing a
show in the same place as me immediately
after me yeah Edinburgh go see it bring
milk jokes oh yeah okay yeah yeah yeah
cos it and then you tweeted that saying
can I incite violence against myself
yeah and then she replied to that I
didn't see that one oh yeah I was asleep
I think you probably should have pissed
on about having a conversation with
myself I'll do that I know I did that at
the time before people knew it was me I
had like would you call her out about no
she called me out on something so I was
I I was on Sky News and I put out a
tweet a clip of it and she quote tweeted
it saying look at this disgusting
straight white male
doing this thing and then I argued back
and I pretended that I didn't realize it
was satire okay so I wasn't real person
I argued back saying look it is really
out of order and then those people
started going to me saying this is
satire may accompany you fell for it
it was really funny and I kept saying
when it wasn't obviously a joke and so I
argue back at them so many layers just
fine of it being built in here so when
it was very very first new yeah I find
it quite cathartic yeah exactly you
could just I just said whatever I want I
still do but these are the problem is
that I haven't learned my lesson really
I just say whatever I want now the
difference is now if I offend people
they come at me deal with the concert
they all come at me and I get I get the
sort of dogpiling on twitter which I
didn't have before because people didn't
know who it was lovely anonymity
previously yeah so we would have
preferred to still be anonymous to be
honest so how did we get from you being
this woke social justice warrior alter
ego yeah person to you now being both
Bruce Wayne and Batman and everyone
knowing that the truth that was okay so
it's a bit of a complicated the book was
um the book came out in March walk link
will be in the show notes below yeah
please buy that gen reason I'm here and
the the book came out much and then
Rosamund Irwin from The Sunday Times
wrote an article in The Sunday Times and
what she said it was actually a really
impressive piece of investigative
journalism what she done is she'd read
my book she'd read um my articles for
spikes online she'd worked out that
there were some quotations that were
similar and some formatic
similarities and then she decided she so
she said I'm 50% certain it's andrew
dial or it could be Lisa graves who ran
the Godfrey elfric account and there's a
pit room and there was a pitcher Lisa so
she pretty much some narrowed it down to
two Lisa had also painted the portrait
to Tania that appears on the book inside
cover
but she's credited so Rosman Irwin was
saying this seems a bit obvious if she's
name and so it was really good a piece
of journalism um she'd found friends of
mine she'd yeah I found out about this
afterwards she did she I know I know
it's proper journalism isn't it that's
like that's like forensic literary yeah
assessment of a twitter care it's quite
funny and then a month earlier her
honestly and then but the smoking gun
came because chortle fact Steve Bennett
Chaucer I don't know how he did it
there was a catalog at a book fair in
Frankfurt which had been issued by the
publishers and someone in the publishing
house hadn't realized that I was to
remain anonymous and heard my name next
to the next to the book but this was
dating months before the book was
released so it tonight I don't know to
this day how he got it I don't but uh
sir I must ask him one day I think it's
really interested it's really impressive
it's impressive what was it so the wood
must have been a day or a moment when
you woke up and went [ __ ] the game's up
well yeah well when I read The Sunday
Times thing I thought it'd be quite
funny I interviewed Lisa graves accusing
her of being as myself sold them a dummy
so then I published that interview but I
never denied it was me I was very
careful with my wording I've never
denied it I didn't even deny it to
Rosman them I went from the times I you
know there was something about the
phrasing when she emailed me and I email
back like just I made sure very
particular I wasn't lying yeah and then
but then when the chortle thinking about
for a while because I'd already turned
down I've been offered interviews and
things they've gone to the PR person at
the the publisher saying could we
interview ever is behind titania as him
or her yeah and I refused those and then
so when this came out I thought I may as
well do all these interviews now I'm
just doubled on them and that's when I
did the Piers Morgan stuff and all the
interviews and things because actually
it happened the week the book was out it
really boosted it it was it was hugely
helpful to the extent that it looks like
I calculate the whole thing but I'm not
that Machiavellian I did like things
just happen like that yeah their dinner
serendipity works weirdly like though
yeah so let's say that someone hasn't
seen the titania account okay how would
you describe it I would describe it as
the kind of social justice activist who
is very humorless is desperate to be
offended desperate to promote of our own
victimhood
and is not necessarily stupid but is uh
but it's I swallowed this ideology
wholesale to the extent that they
stopped being able to think for
themselves and it's like any ideology
isn't it if you just follow our an
ideology without without questioning any
of its tenets and you end up basically
mindless you end up just like a zombie
like a kind of religious seller and
that's what I wanted to talk
not saying a lot of the smartest people
I know have bought into this cult of
identity politics and they end up saying
really really stupid things
it's I saw it the other day I was
reading The New Yorker review of the new
Quentin Tarantino film Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood and it's a guy in The New
Yorker who is obviously extremely bright
obviously but the review in the review
he says genuinely stupid things because
he's seeing it through the prism of
identity politics he actually says at
one point it's a ridiculously white film
which is not a serious criticism you can
never let a film you know it's it's it's
really dumb they did it with Dunkirk
when don't Kirk Hammett the Christopher
Nolan film on more than one critic
through three or four made the point
that oh the representation of people of
color there's not sufficient
representations like if that's all you
can do if you watch that film and that's
what you come out with how many boxes is
it ticking yeah you know if that's all
you can come up with then to be honest
you're not really a critic at all no
you're just an ideologue you know our
artists don't make choices on the basis
of representation and what they feel
they're feeding out to society that when
real artists oh yeah they care about the
work and the integrity of the work and
the and also this lady's film by
Tarantino so much of the coverage has
been his treatment of women you know the
fact that Sharon Tate in the film
doesn't speak very often this is the man
who produced death Proof which is an
overtly feminist film as far as I
consider the Kill Bill both parts Jackie
Brown which is his best film which is an
incredible characterization of this of
this let you know old a middle-aged
black woman in America Pam Grier is
fantastic in that film and he knows he
sort of brought her back to the
published public consciousness the idea
that he's he's not he's not great at the
representation of women is absurd
actually I think part of it is - it
started with the hateful eight in it
because there was the treatment of the
Daisy dhammika character was so violent
that she be continually punched but he
hates all his characters Mark Kermode
point this out his complete contempt for
all of his characters he doesn't care
about no one Kurt no one else careful no
you told you right so like why are we
why are we seeing art works through way
it just means you you can't you can't
you're not judging things on their own
merits anymore mm-hmm and it's a real
shame actually
yeah I agree one of the things that's
interesting so for me I'm not massively
political I'm a red-blooded capitalist
and have worked for myself as a
sovereign individual since I was like 18
okay so my exposure to the world of
politics is very very focused on myself
yeah my vote if I was to vote which I
haven't in any of never voted once
really know that once there's an
educated guy I've always been aware and
hard very busy with work or doing
whatever it is but if I was to vote one
of the first things that would come up
would be how does this affect my
intricate okay and that's nice hi and
see what political okay fair enough yeah
um you tweeted an article which I read
earlier on which is really broken down a
lot of the things I wish that I could
understand
Brigit fantasy yeah and it's called the
battle cry of the politically homeless
and what she says is that people who
don't have extremist views on either
sides in the spectrum or people who just
aren't bothered about politics kind of
get lambasted as being these wasteful of
always a cooked serve ative yeah yeah
and a waste of a vote and then on top of
that anyone who is but is moderate yeah
anyone who has a slightly nuanced view
yeah just gets sort of thrown to the
wayside and I think that with titania
what you're identifying is that the
people who are the absolute extreme yeah
that's but it is funny for that reason
that people can identify well most
people the vast majority people can't
identify with them at all yeah exactly
that's the I only read that article this
morning that he's a great article
amazing she's brilliant she's an
American comic who has had a lot of
flack for just being honest about her
opinions and her opinions as far as I
can see I'm not particularly
controversial you know nevertheless yes
she's talking about that idea that
there's an expectation now that you
should be politicized Taylor Swift
Khadija members she got so much flak for
not condemning Trump you know and it's
like Taylor Swift silence is deafening
so I don't need to know Taylor Swift's
opinion on politics just a Taylor Swift
for political advice it's that one
little mix tweeted about the bombing of
Syria they sent an apology saying - I
was so sorry to the people of Syria I
bet the people of Syria were thinking
great thank God at least
makes have got our back well I think
look I'm not saying these people we
shouldn't have the right to have an
opinion of course they do but I don't
give a [ __ ] what say what little makes
think about Syria yeah that's not there
that's not their expertise is it so
anyway yeah so this is expectation but
also what what Bridget's talking about
in that article is the way in which
actually because if you express an
honest opinion and then you get this
kind of barrage of hatred off the back
of it it means that people are becoming
nervous about just being honest so you
the discourse is dominated by the
extremes so you have the the woke left
who are really myopic and just cannot
see beyond their own very narrow house
or the parameters and if you step
outside a particular you come from the
left like I do and you step outside it
just a little bit you are the most
you're the persona non-grata you're the
other one thing it's straight down there
yeah yeah and and and and so people who
have moderate views people who just want
to have a discussion about some of these
difficult issues they want to address
the nuance of say the trans debate they
will just be lambasted as bigots was the
big irony with this is these people that
know what the word bigot means I mean
the definition of bigot is someone who
is incapable or completely intolerant of
anyone else's opinion someone who has a
different opinion but they the people
serve nine times attend anyone who calls
you a bigot is nominee that's good
because what they're saying is your
opinion shouldn't be allowed yeah I
shouldn't you know we shouldn't have to
it shouldn't be tolerated so yeah it's a
real problem Bridget's been on the
receiving end of it a lot of us have now
and of course what happens as well as if
you express an opinion that isn't within
that Overton Window of acceptable for
people just say well you're being
dishonest you're being a provocateur
you're being a shock jock because it's a
kind of narcissistic worldview that I
can't believe that someone else would
have a different view than me
therefore this must be a lie yeah right
so I mean my my my
I suppose my guiding principle is just
to tell the truth say what I think yes
and see what happens right and I
everyone did that can you imagine with
me a live me in a much better position
when we yeah well do you know Jordan
Peterson who
a fan favorite of the show he his first
rule tell the truth or at least do not
lie he makes the point in his book at
about this actually that is actually
very self-destructive to be dishonest
and I'm when I read that I really chimed
with me I think that's absolutely right
the you're hurting yourself if you if
you're dishonest and he also makes the
point that absolutely there are times
where lying is actually the
compassionate thing to do right fine but
actually the way to do just that evading
the truth icing you don't have to do
lies of omission not lives of ecology
yeah yeah if it's a for a compassionate
reason that make that make sense to me
but I think when it comes to just
expressing your opinions and views it's
all about respecting people enough to
tell them the truth is in I can respect
you I can say some that I think you
might disagree with because I respect
you enough as a human being not to die
assume you're not going to start
throwing things and call me a Nazi right
now you're gonna have a debate again
have a discussion yeah it's actually
really disrespectful to say what you
think the popular viewpoint is just for
the sake of other people's sensibilities
that's actually very disrespectful to
them because you're patronizing them
you're infantilizing them you're saying
that you wouldn't be able to cope with
dissent you know it's a bit like being a
screen um in your school like it's
particularly thing with boys at school
is that you won't say an opinion unless
you're sure everyone else at grills
right yeah right and sometimes your this
happened to me all the time well you
must how could you like when you were a
kid someone said something and
everyone's like oh no we don't think
that do we yeah and then it's like oh no
I didn't mean that
yeah actually sort of stand up doing a
bit about this this year where he's
talking about he when when a situation
arises in the news and he he offers an
opinion a bit too early when it's not
formed and then he start all no can I
take that back
yeah and which is what teenagers do this
isn't a teenage act by the way but it
but that's what teenagers do and it's
that thing of well actually we'd all be
better off being honest if it we know
who we were voting for we'd know what
people think and we know where we stand
we'd have our views challenged there's
all sorts of reasons why honesty is a
good thing but no matter how many times
I say that does a matter people just say
yeah you're lying you just lying because
you want to cause trouble order and
that's really sad know anyone who wants
to read a very good short book online
sam harris is like one
how can one Iomega and it is a one our
justification for why you should never
lie yeah and it's absolutely great
highly highly recommended will be linked
in these shown up to the low but I get
it I keep getting messages from people
saying I really like what you're doing I
can't tweet about it honestly I I had
one the other day from quite a prominent
actor say I really really like I saw the
show actually said I really like the
tiny show I can't tweet about it cuz I
can't be bothered with the back I should
I'm gonna face the back - so he's
sympathize with that why should they but
you know why should there be a backlash
for expressing an opinion but she Brigid
mentions in the article which is the the
best way I've seen to put it that people
aren't voting out of habit or for their
own interests it's now a comment on your
personal I don't like and worth quite so
let's take the brexit vote whether the
media reduced it to leave equals bad
remain equals good not just the media
but sort of the people in this not very
middle class circle that that's how they
reduced it leave equals racist remain
equals compassionate yeah and non racist
okay it's a lie that everyone bought
into it's pathetic and it's the left
well it's exactly it's that reductive
thing of reducing actually a very
complicated new ins political question
to an easy shortcut you know why do you
think that people are doing that at the
moment why are people reducing down
difficult discussions to these real
tweet lengths there's a good
psychological reason there's a think of
the cognitive misers and model which
means that you you instinctively try and
find the easiest to train of thought
your mind that your you'll always go for
the easiest it actually takes a bit of
effort to think about things if if
you've got this situation for instance
with the brakes of oh and you can just
say well that's how it's good in that
size evil well it sees it's an easy
choice to make otherwise you have to
start not understanding the issues
there's a whole lot harder I get that
and it yeah it started talking a lot
happen with Trump it's happening now
with with with Boris Johnson so there's
gonna be it's the same thing against are
you a good person and this is why the
polls never work anymore this is why no
one predicted Trump no one predicted
brexit it never works because
people have their opinions they have
have two sets of opinions but they've
got the opinions that they actually feel
and they've got the opinions that they
know they can express in public right
and those two are no longer the same it
used to be the case that they were the
same I remember talking to an old trade
unionist about this super saying that
you know we used to be able to talk to
like some of the miners and everything
about and they would be really
homophobic they'd say like you know they
hate [ __ ] and all this oil didn't use
[ __ ] that said queers back then with no
maggots but you know but they were right
on all these other issues and rather
than bulk and that and say or whether
you're obviously a fascist I won't talk
to you about anything this guy was
saying what I'd say to them is well ok
you're right about these social issues
and these economic issues so can we now
talk about your issues about sexuality
and and then it became a discussion and
then people change their minds and that
was the that's a great thing to happen
right but now if say for instance you've
got one opinion that is not acceptable
say you are anti-abortion right so that
for many leftists is like one of the the
sins Cardinals Fawcett right so if
you're in that then then suddenly we
write off for you we write you off
completely yeah so even if we agree on
other things it doesn't matter anymore
you're now at the bad person you're now
an evil person it's really
unsophisticated yeah and it's perfectly
this is why I end up agreeing with
people who on the whole I can't I don't
agree with on anything and for instance
um let's take the free speech question
you know so I am NOT a nationalist I
would never vote you kit on the basis a
Nationalist Party and I'm not
nationalists so fundamentally I I don't
have anything in common with them but
they're right about free speech right so
that they recognize that there's a
problem with free speech the Labour
Party in the Tory Party are both against
free speech both of them are for hate
speech laws for instance the Labour
Party want to push more press regulation
if at all possible Theresa May is one of
the worst when it comes to free speech I
mean she she since her she denied Tyler
the Creator and entrance to the UK on
the base of her rap he's done right
which is great because then he did an
auntie Teresa maha wrap which sounds
really surreal people forget about that
but I did that did actually happen I
didn't dream so when you've got the two
major parties of anti-free speech you
you've got to be able to say this other
party that I have nothing
in common with that actually I can't
really stand I I am they aren't right
about that
but you say that and then also I'll your
UKIP's Porter ah no not Hamburg like
never this tiny little sliver there
correct about have what they're saying
and no one gets their own principles all
right so our principle is either right
or it's wrong okay so you you should be
able to say I I don't approve of
anything that person says or does but on
that they're right because they don't
own the principle there's no more room
for new ones
no no 13 discussions now so the thing
that keeps coming back to me and again
I'm I'm probably a good avatar for the
layperson when it comes to seeing these
things right yes I'm not embroiled in
them and it it feel for you I know it
must feel like it would be heaven for
you right um looking from the outside in
yeah people who were getting upset at
the fact that you're making comedy at
these situations to me that is
potentially the most shocking thing of
all because Armando Iannucci
must be itching his script to have a go
at brats it I'm Boris Johnson with
another season of the thick of it and
there must be you know there must is the
I think he said you could never do the
thicker bone again there's an answer cut
couple years ago because of because he
says things have got to do surreal well
yeah there we go but you know I mean
like to me it looks like the perfect
breeding ground the current political
climate is the perfect breeding ground
for some comedy and some Saturn yeah
yeah of course
yeah it's it's ideal um better than
people who say that to me is like isn't
it hard to saturate like people like
Trump who is self satirizing the
funniest thing said about Trump are by
himself right there on his Twitter feed
yeah you're right you know I mean um two
days ago with their to leave you know
the thing about receded to leave who do
who'd write sort of talking politics
again but she looked for she'd asked to
go to Israel to visit her 19 year old
grandmother on humanitarian grounds and
Israel had denied her entry ins because
she was likely to criticize the Israeli
government in and she said she said in a
letter I won't mention public don't
criticize I just wanna see my
grandmother they came back saying okay
and then she was like oh this is
disgusting I'm not going there because
they demanding that I say certain things
it was a total political move but then
Trump tweeted of Harriet saying well the
only winner in this situation is her
grandmother who won't have to say
let's be honest that's a funny tweet now
look I don't support Trump and I'm also
kind of I'm old-fashioned about policy I
don't want my politician to be funny
yeah I want them to be serious because
it's a serious job yeah but I can look
at that and say that's funny I can look
at that and say that's a funny tweet he
has a point
even though I don't like most of what he
stands for wish I'd written it yeah
there we go that's not good but it's
funnier because it's the president yeah
there is something funny about the idea
of the president the United States
calling Kim jong-un fat that's funny
because it you should never happen it's
also scary because they're both nuclear
powers but yeah it's like yes thank you
pretty high there so again I should
reiterate I'm not supportive of it I
wish he didn't do it
yeah but I also look let in love what
are you gonna do laughs doesn't
involuntary responses now I don't
calculate like like the workset seem to
be able to do I mean the work the work
idea is that you you look you hear a
joke you think about it you assess who
are the marginalized groups is it
punching up is it punching down can I
laugh about yes good Amit laughter they
see it as this kind of transaction right
that's not how it works sometimes I
laugh for the most horrible
inappropriate things because they are
horrible in an appropriate because that
sort stuff reminds us why we don't talk
about those things you can see a Jerry
SATA wit show you know and and good luck
watching you Jerry south of it's showing
not being offended at some point yeah
everyone's getting F he's gonna offend
you at some point there's gonna be a
moment where you think that's that's too
much you shouldn't do that and that's
part there's something quite
exhilarating about that yeah you can be
offended and laugh at it
happens to me all the time I'm quite
sensitive I get offended easily but it's
my problem
it's basically yeah that's funny
um one of the things that I've been
thinking about when seeing the way that
we recently had zoobi on the show yeah
um because of this weird game playing he
had the left stun with language and
social constructs and things like that
yeah to me what it appears to have
allowed are very clever people to game
that system right and zu B's tweet about
breaking the women's deadlift
record psi identify this woman
be a bigot yeah that is a perfect
example of regaining this the little
gaps that they've been created yeah I
the left in that yeah is that one of the
one of the things that you think that is
helping us to identify where they're in
consistencies within their views and
stuff
I think ridicule is what does it best of
all and and and part of the way you do
that is you take on board their language
the problem with that is you find
yourself tempted to play though them by
their rules so when they talk about
privilege and all that I've seen this
happen a lot and there's an argument
about privilege and they often throw out
this idea of white privilege this
blanket idea that if you're white you
are inherently privileged which of
course is not true some white people are
privileged some are right in more sorts
of ways there's all kinds of ways you
can be privileged right it's not just to
do with race ethnicity and sexuality but
yes so you end up with the situation
where people buy into the victimhood
thing and they'll say okay I've been
accused to being privileged to have them
come back and say actually no I I went
to a rough school I went grew up on a
little stay I did ride one right and
then you're getting into this company
you're playing their role yes back at
them and that's probably not healthy you
know you can do it like you can and when
they fall foul of their own rules which
they often do alright did you see the
the Democratic conference in America
where someone made a point of personal
privilege yeah yeah and the point of
personal privilege work was guys can you
just keep the void annoys down because
I'm very sensitive I get sensory
overload and I get triggered then
someone said point of personal privilege
drat that point of personal privilege
don't say guys that's gendered language
I'm really offended by that don't do
that so you have people calling out each
other's calling out it's like this
endless inception of woken us yeah right
so so we could do that too so we could
we could point out where they are being
triggering I mean let's let's take an
example most of the work lot who are
really anti brexit tend to be incredibly
ageist they're basically saying we can't
wait for the old people to die old
people who [ __ ] over the country
they're basically evil it's like are you
kidding you're you know you're the
person who goes on all the time about
being sensitive and and you know and
surely what ageism is part of that isn't
it or is that just your blind spot so
then if we call them outrages and we
become part of that game yeah so I
thought refused to play the game
that's that's something that I've been
I've got written down here is something
I told you can't work out but you're
gonna help me do okay you may have been
in a relationship but a lot of listen as
well as me where your partner brings up
a particular issue you don't care about
this issue I can do you spoke to that
girl or you didn't reply in time or your
you were late or something like that
yeah that's not an issue that you
usually would do but they set precedent
by doing that yeah and then what you
find yourself doing next time that
something happens that you find them
culpable for that same thing for yeah if
you go in a second are you talking to
that guy yeah I didn't care and I still
don't care but I'm going to use the
opportunity to identify your
inconsistency yeah that's straight off
the bat yeah and that push and pull yeah
that happens in relationships I think is
very similar to what's happening here
yeah I almost think that looking at the
way that the left has kind of adopted
this the way that andino was assaulted
in the street and they're taking bike
lot surrounded throwing no checks of
people you know that would have been a
characteristic of the right previously
however very aggressive approach right
and it's almost like they're absorbing
taking on that persona that push and
pull thing and then you think well I'm
in a second if you keep on doing that as
the left and throwing bike locks around
there are some people on the right who
have got very very large guns right
exactly
well there's two there's two sort of
points there I think I think one of them
is is well actually not just the left
that do it was the right do it as well
we saw that with the Joe Brown case you
know in Joe Brown made the joke about
throwing battery acid at Nigel for Amish
which was obviously a joke whether you
found it funny or not but irrelevant but
it was most people on the right saying
she should be arrest if it or she should
be investigated by the police all the
same people who complain about their
very authoritarian treatment of comedy
on the hole right and people who
completely because you say that free
speech is under threat and then all of a
sudden they're the people saying
actually no but Joe Brown should be
investigate exactly inciting violence no
you've got to be consistent in your
principles either left or right that's
really really important because it means
your own principles will get undermined
the other point about anti-fat which
the group the anti-fascist group now I
for one mistrust anyone who identifies
as anti-fascist that let me just say
that because for star I assume everyone
is right my assumption of you will be
out that you're not a fascist yeah it's
very same right yeah okay I will assume
that of everyone until I hear
extraordinary evidence to the contrary
if I find the evidence fine yeah but we
have to ask there's hardly any fascist
has it's like an answer you dog hugger
yeah exactly exactly you don't declare
that do you it'll declare that you don't
have a predilection to penetrate
livestock see do you I don't know and I
wouldn't assume that you would have yeah
you know although now we're talking
about my suspicions I know you see but
look and I see on Twitter webs I'm
auntie fat proud anti-fascist like you
don't need to tell me that and it makes
me suspicious right what you're
projecting it yeah exactly the same as
the people who there's a statistic
somewhere that you see font of the
co-hosts to the show's pile yeah people
that are very very so fit really about
being against gays yeah I have the ones
that are most aroused when they see yeah
that he studies into that has been
studied I mean they they literally
measured the extent of people's arousal
yeah you know to like how hard they got
basically on the band and it tended to
be when the most overtly homophobe if
you've watched gay porn it's so it's but
it's such a no-brainer of course it is
cuz why would you care yeah why do you
care is something lurking in the active
yeah it's pretty it's big I mean the
date is in on that one yeah oh man it's
not surprising but the point about
antiphon yeah and if I effectively end
up behaving like fascists don't they end
up behaving like that's the thing that's
so funny about it yeah like anyone who
seeks to silence someone through
violence is is at the very least
employing a tactic that the fascists
also employed so you know I probably
stopped short short of calling them
actual facts lightning crashes of the
very specific historical meaning but
there's certainly fascistic ten
tendencies or strategies I mean I read a
Brett and Mark Pryor I think my brace
book about anti far and what's very
interesting it's very well written
actually what's interesting about it is
he does a very good job of sort of
outlining all the history of the
anti-fascist movements and things like
cable street you know
[Music]
what whether the people confronted the
possible Mosley's Brownshirts so all of
that and that's very good there's a lot
that stuff I didn't know about it's all
very interesting but because those are
genuine anti-fascist a movement isn't
you know these are the you know know the
kiddies version right exactly so what
what the book fails to do quite
spectacularly actually is connect to
those movements to what is happening now
and makes the assumption that the people
we're dealing with are in fact fascists
and that assumption is wrong okay so
some of them are fascists some of them
are white supremacists sure right most
of them are you saw you see Trump
supporters getting pepper spray people
anyone wearing a mag are getting kicked
to the ground there was someone who had
oh they make Bitcoin great we don't hurt
that got really just cuz they didn't
read it problem yeah they couldn't read
the right Bitcoin instead of now if you
can't distinguish between an actual
white supremacist and someone who votes
trunk and that isn't to say that white
supremacist couldn't vote Trump they
could and they might do but just because
you vote Trump it doesn't follow that
you're a white supremacist that will
still be a massive minority of the
people to vote of a trump right so if
you can't make that distinction then you
aren't politically and historically in a
trip and what's worse is if you can't
make the distinction and you have that
level of literacy and you've got a
baseball bat and a mask that's a
dangerous combination right you know I
mean we saw with and II know a bunch of
white middle class students in masks
beating up a gay Vietnamese immigrant in
the name of Father in the name of
tolerance and to you know to stand up
against white supremacy are you
subscribe nearing it's at a time your
tweet so it's really funny and also
horrible yeah it's horrible because
sorry even well yeah he was hurt he was
injured it was unjust
what they should have done that would
obviously all this stems for not from an
article he wrote or a couple of articles
you wrote for Colette what you do in
that case if you disagree with the
journalist is you go up to them and say
oh I disagree with this can we have a
discussion about it that's it and as
soon as you hit someone on the basis of
they are normalizing supremacist
language or discourse you you know you
over theorized to justify your own
violence addict's and it can't be
justified mm-hmm
and it's really really sad that we've
got to this point where this isn't
happening is all of this just reaction
is it still this big hangover
from Trump being elected partly I mean
I'm sure there's a frustration about it
Trump I suppose was the start of it
wasn't that and because people just
decided that he was a fascist because
they didn't really know what fascist
meant you know he said a lot of stuff
that I find contemptible and a lot of
stuff that I think you would be hard
pushed I think when he talked about in
an Omar and the squadron and said send
them how they can get they should just
go home I mean three of the four were
born in a member they were born in
America and the fourth is a US citizen
anyway right it's difficult for me to
see how that can be interpreted as
anything other than a racist trope
actually so but this does not
necessarily mean he's a white
supremacist that's a massive leap to
make again I'd need the evidence on it
but yeah I think I think that's the
problem is that there's a sense of
frustration people were angry
understandably so you know it's not nice
to lose is it and it's easier if you can
then paint everyone in rain that thing
happen as evil if you say that everyone
in vote for Trump is as deplorable as
Hillary Clinton remember so memorably
did and that worked out really well for
it didn't it then of course you you go
on the offensive and you end up
guaranteeing Trump's victory in 2020
that's what you do that's what they've
done what would you predict what's
definitely in a win your key yeah I mean
the way to play a very smart game
because he's putting this the squad
before Democrat politicians who play
identity politics all the time
so in an Omaha Alexandra occasion Cortes
Hannah Presley and and receded to leave
who are never going to play well with
the electorate because they were always
going on about grievance and
intersectionality and white privilege
and all that sort of stuff that doesn't
win votes never has never will and what
Trump is doing is he constantly talks
about them to make them the face of the
Democrat Party so in answer to those
giving them enough rope yes not
computer-like Pelosi I hating this like
sheet sheet she wants a distance asset
from from these four but when you think
Democrat now you think Boober woke crazy
identitarian right that's largely
because of Trump and because the way he
puts him at sent at the census as a
smile tactical move the Democrats need
to distance themselves from this kind of
politics identity politics never works
and what's so funny about white why
doesn't work
it divides everyone up it says you know
you stay in your lane over here you stay
in your lane we're gonna we're gonna
really help you will help the Hispanics
will help the gays will help the women
you know with anyone else I think what
about us what about us you know and then
becomes competing competing interests
you can only win an election by unity by
saying that we are doing what's best for
absolutely everyone and because the
worker movement is essentially a
movement that that rehabilitates racial
thinking it makes us think about race
more image think about sexuality and it
makes us aware to the point of
discrimination and it and it and it
separates us all out and it wants to
undo the work of the civil rights
movements it wants to undo the work of
Martin Luther King it wants us no longer
to think about content of character but
to think about color of skin so it's a
regressive backward movement it isn't
helpful human rights it feeds the
far-right it helps the far-right the
far-right is on the rise there still
thankfully very fringe group but they
are on the rise because of the woke
movement because the woke left giving
them all the ammunition they need okay
because if you constantly say that all
these working-class white people you're
just privileged all you boys you're just
rapists in waiting you know you've got
toxic masculinity you should be ashamed
of yourself all of this sort of stuff
and then you've got the alt-right
white nationalist group saying well come
come to us then we're not going to treat
not because it becomes an almost
moderate and attractive exact place to
be exactly and that's a really
terrifying prospect for me the main
reason i attack the woke left is because
I'm scared of the rise of the far-right
that genuinely frightens me because
where is the woke left or well
intentioned on the whole I think they're
well-intentioned they want they want the
world to get a place they're just in a
cult so they can't see the reality of it
right you know it's like anyone in a
cult if they they're believing they're
believers right it's not evil they see
the world as full of fascists they see
the world is full of injustice and they
want to do something about it that's a
laudable aim the problem is the world
isn't for the fascist and they just end
up hitting people with bite rocks
because they vote the wrong way right
Sophia so that's that's that's the
problem all of that does is generate all
of this resentment and and hope it's a
gift it's a boon to the genuine like
really vile white supremacists all right
just-just repugnant people who can
thrive on this stuff but what you know
that's as far as I can see the only way
to get beyond that is to is to is to
take down the won't left to make it okay
to mock them again to restore reasonable
political conversation that's what we
need to do is so important
there must be so there's a really
interesting podcast Eric Weinstein on
Joe Rogan okay and Eric I've seen Joe
Rogan focus a lot I haven't seen that so
Eric is the managing director of teal
capital Peter teal one of the PayPal
mafia yeah companies and he is fairly
widely regarded as one of the smartest
people like public intellectuals upon it
and he has this really interesting point
he makes about how the moderates on both
the left and the right are allowing the
extremists of that side to do all of the
work for ya and then by not shouting up
as someone who's moderate left and
saying hang in a second that's wrong or
by being moderate right and saying hang
in a second that's also wrong when
Charlotte goes wrong yeah whatever it
might be you are he says it with much
money you want to this he says
essentially you're supporting it by not
by saying oh well you can you can go out
as a vanguard of your particular
political leaning yeah push them forward
a little bit yeah yeah I think you we
can't shout shout louder than the
lunatics can do that they do they do
dominate they really do yeah I mean
that's a very good I think it's I think
Prince in the case of Charlottesville is
it is quite important people on that
side of the debate to say this is wrong
it's you know it's it you know it's not
right before it Trump's us to suggest a
moral equivalence between people who are
opposed to fascism and people who murder
in the name of white supremacy that's
not that's not right I mean the the the
the anti fascist peaceful protesters I'm
behind 100% while I'm not behind is the
ones who Don the masks commit acts of
violence that's a very different dragon
old man out of his car and the driver
redirect him in traffic right that's a
very different it's important because
I'm I think peaceful protest is the way
all the time peaceful protest and
ridicule
but yes certainly so so sorry to go back
to the points I've missed it I've gotten
our different extremes x-range pulling
it for the for the moderate people yeah
well I think that goes back to what
Bridget was saying doesn't it is that
when a movement gets characterized by
its worst elements that's the problem in
the way that Islam for instance has been
mischaracterized by its most reactionary
elements and observed you get the same
thing here where suddenly you think of
the left I mean if I say the left what
do you think of you think of these
screeching offense seekers don't you you
think of the muggle hair yeah you think
of the worst well actually that's not
being on the left means you know it's
and and that's a real shame so I think
yeah I think we need to restore
moderation I think we need to be we need
to stop having feel T to ideology so
that we can say yeah broadly speaking my
principles are left-wing but that that
that you've just said this right winger
has said this interesting thing which I
might take on board in that can we adopt
as well mm-hm
and then and restore the nature of the
individual the individual is sovereign
as John Stuart Mill said like the it
matters what you think you have to have
to be a free thinker not let other
people do your thinking for you and
that's where we've got to where people
don't they don't do that anymore
yeah like if if you if you were on the
Left saying you told me one of your
principles I could pretty much guess
what all your other views are and that
should never be the case you should
surprise me now and then with what you
think did you see Jordan Pederson on GQ
no this interview is fantastic I'll send
you it for you
but wait with Helen Lewis maybe it was
it was a one-to-one into two hours long
yes they tried to take me down there was
lots of oh yeah sorry I let you down
it's going really weird title I totally
did um yeah and in that she says she
starts asking him these questions and he
just starts laughing at it yeah and he
says because your questions are
ridiculous from the first question that
you asked me yeah I could have predicted
every subsequent question okay we're
going to give ya exactly exactly
that's it play now in front of ya in
that sad like and no one wants to be
predictable anyway you know no but I
think but that's what I think that's
what the left are trying to do here yeah
trying to go like how with how much
fidelity can I become offended yeah like
with how high-rez
Ellucian can I look at discrimination
like and continue to one-up it's the
point of personal privilege at this
point of personal privilege EVs work
guys
like it's the one upmanship I mean I'm
always a bit wary of that just because I
don't like to guess what people are
thinking I don't like to guess people's
intentions you know so like when we talk
about virtue signaling right which is I
think what you're referring to it
definitely goes on you know I mean
everyone knows this so the particular
politicians do this a lot you know they
talk about they want people to know how
upset they are about a certain thing or
whatever but by the same token I don't
want to assume that with it that they're
doing that for the worst motives I don't
want to assume that about them you know
but I don't know it's the problem of you
having faith in people
it's in front of you it's literally is
the problem of you hoping for the best
in people and we do it well it's partly
that but it's also that I can't it's a
gate that goes back to everything about
not playing by their rules right the one
that the thing that I get all the time
is people telling me what I secretly
think that's the one common factor I get
it all the time so people say or do they
say you think well so actually virtually
all the major criticisms of me on
Twitter the people who really go for me
have decided that I have these secret
racist thoughts that I have internalized
homophobia that I thought I had one the
other day about how I I mean what am i
right who knows right all this stuff is
like you're a right wing you're a Tory I
get that a lot of Tory I've never voted
Tory it doesn't matter yeah they know
that secretly I have they know my secret
thoughts running and that's a problem
and then if I turn around and say yeah
but you secretly think this then I'm
just reducing myself to their level so
what I will always do is take an
argument of face value I'm never going
to assume someone's lying about their
argument for whatever reason because the
argument will be demolished irrespective
of the truth behind it mm-hm you can you
can defeat a bad argument whether the
person is sincere about it or not
so that I think is a much better
strategy and I'm sure there are people
who are paid for extreme opinions you
know III think we all know who were
talking about right people you know
people who will put extreme opinions out
there because it gets them clickbait
yeah you know um but the argument either
stands or falls on its own merit it
doesn't really matter with
mm-hmm and also you can't demolish the
argument by assuming they don't mean it
because you've got their evidence for
that yeah that's just your aspecting I
got to defeat you on its own terms
yeah it's Marie I'm gonna bring up what
I spoke to zubi about the other day on
us which is Mario Lopez the guy who
played AC Slater on Saved by the Bell
which you never watched so I never
watched it - shaimaa - it's a good TV
show is it so Mary Lopez says this very
very over-over pedestrian yeah caveat
after caveat a very very mild I'm not
sure if three-year-olds should be
allowed to change their gender yeah
that's essentially what he says and then
is annihilated and a couple of days
later it comes back with the most
groveling apology comments I made were
ignorant and insensitive and they now
have a deeper understanding of how
hurtful they were I have been and always
will be an ardent supporter of the
lgbtq+ community and I'm going to use
this opportunity to better educate
myself moving forward I will be more
informed and thoughtful right well every
time someone does that it gives more
power to the Worker movement and it
gives it gives that sort of Twitter mob
the the upper hand because it means they
know it works
it's like capitulate to terrorists you
know once you want to do it they know it
works and they'll do it again and again
and again we've seen it all the time
people are forced to apologize for
things they said years ago things that
probably weren't even that offensive
that's not offensive that's an opinion
so and if you really believed it or we
didn't right if you believed it stand by
it yeah you know I mean it's sure you
can change your mind about stuff in
three days unlikely that degree what you
were actually having is a lot of
pressure from you know I mean people can
say to him but maybe someone sat down
said I'll think about this thing about
there's any get change line that's
possible right even in that case I would
advise not apologizing because it just
feeds the beast yeah you know I doubt we
saw this with Kevin Hart and the Oscars
for jokes he tweeted eight years ago ten
years ago something like that and they
were jokes doesn't matter if they're
offensive they were jokes I I don't care
so again I probably but a good for him
he didn't apology said I thought he said
I apologize that the
I'm not gonna keep apologizing for this
yeah you know
did you see the Liam Neeson thing about
it in February time yeah he said that
his close family member had been
sexually assaulted
I did like black guy so he walked around
his hometown with a cosh yeah just going
into black neighborhoods hoping to find
someone that was associate yeah and like
whoa
hang on a second what's this guy
supposed to say because I found although
it's obviously quite a dark story yeah I
found it very very interesting yeah oh
my gosh this is this is how would I feel
what would what would I do in that
situation how would I act in that
situation you thinking about Liam Neeson
this guy yeah yeah believe voice walking
around the dark streets of Ireland with
this caution his hand and I'm like what
an amazing story yeah I can't believe he
said it actually I can't believe he said
that to a journalist then they even
didn't think about the consequences of
saying it but there is something to be
said for his honesty it's but it's a
horrible it's a horrible idea that
someone can be so traumatized by
something they behave in such a vile way
and by his own admission it was a vile
and you know it did his own shock after
himself yeah but does that not like that
sort of a thing educates everybody yeah
yeah that's sort of a story cuz I'm like
I've never heard anything like that
before yeah even in fiction I've never
heard anything like that before and I
think Wow but what was your interest
what was weird about that is it I don't
know why the woke movement got so angry
about that because actually what he was
making was a really woke point because
they believe that white people are
essentially racist anyway and so this
was just sort bolstering their view so I
don't know why they weren't happy about
this to be honest but yeah they went for
him it's an unforgiving I mean this is
the thing about the whole the whole woke
things you can never if you make a
mistake once you were tired for life you
can never be forgiven because it is a
religion and they don't think redemption
is possible because those why than Mario
Lopez you've got this window of whatever
like maybe yes seven days or something
like that within which you can recount
right and as long as you do your self
flagellation over whatever particular TV
station or your press release it is that
you do then maybe you get right but that
I mean and the point he was raising is
it
discussion we need to have right the
question about gender is a discussion we
absolutely need to have so anyone who
knows anything about gender has read
sort of theories of gender gender is not
as the worker movement claimed a social
construct it is a very very complicated
combination of social and biological
factors right and the problem is that
their faith-based position about gender
has been as been adopted particular in
Canada for instance by governments and
actually we need to have a much bigger
discussion before these sort of policies
are adopted we need to actually talk
about and decide whether they're right
or not it's not correct that that gender
is solely something to do with culture
largely I mean certainly the the obvious
example is that you dress boys in blue
and girls in pink whereas in fact you
know go back hundred two hundred years
it was the reverse right so those things
are arbitrary feminism second white
feminism spent years trying to break
down the idea of of gender norms and
gender stereotyping right what's wrong
with a boy being effeminate with what
why'd you start questioning his name
well that's maybe he's a girl now maybe
he's an effeminate boy and that's okay
what's wrong with a girl being a tomboy
being butch well it's like what there's
none that do you remember tomboys yet
because Tom boys haven't been around as
far as I can remember for about ten
words when in fact the recent play of
the was a teeny blind claim was it
Mallory towers even and they cast a
non-binary actor to play the tomboy
character okay it was an Emma rice
production know that this says this says
a lot that it's almost like the concept
of a butch girl is now something we
don't understand anymore no no no it's a
boy in a girl's body this is deeply
conservative right it's it's hugely
conservative I saw a documentary at
trans kids where the the parents were
talking about they're there because they
said that we've got this little girl now
and we're so happy because we don't have
to watch our little boy mincing about
like Leah play something like a little
gay all right
so we fixed him we fixed about Mike you
know and without any sense of
self-awareness or but actually that
points to a very interesting thing about
the trans debate which we're not really
addressing is to what extent is he's
actually just a rehabilitated homophobia
to
what extent is this just us fixing
people into rigid ideas of what it means
to be a man and what it means to be a
woman I remember seeing a debate between
Performa Tatars could David Hoyle and
Lauren Harris who is a transgender woman
was formerly a man in his family male
and Lauren said where he during the
interview she said I always knew I was a
woman because I used to buy lots of
shoes right which actually just is
endorsing the most base gross stereotype
about women and commercialism that you
can imagine women aren't all Imelda
Marcos you know they don't have that's
not what it in wardrobes yeah it doesn't
mean you're a woman just because you
like to I used to play with dolls as a
kid I'm not a woman yeah you know it
doesn't matter and so that's my big
concern that's what I would like to have
that I'm not saying that I know all the
answers or that I have a full
understanding of the situation what I am
saying is I've read a lot about it and I
would like to have a serious proper
public discussion about these issues
without being shouted at and called a
transfer over and have someone hit me
with a bike and bike lock enough have a
milkshake on my face well be being able
to be under the age of 16 and not being
allowed to have sex but being allowed to
change your sex right it's not viously a
problem because having sex will last for
probably first time maybe about three
minutes but like changing your sexes the
rusty life right it's it's it's a really
seriously you know but I've composed no
one identifying this I have total
sympathy with someone who genuinely
feels that they are in in the wrong body
of quality um yes so so so so to suggest
that to have misgivings about any kind
of chemical interventional puberty
inhibitor of offer of a child is not the
same thing as being anti trans rights it
should be actually the two are
completely compatible we need to have a
serious discussion about that right but
we're not having that discussion we're
just throwing insults it's really sad so
I wanted to finish with some questions
for titania
as if how would she answer right so
pretty hard I know you're gonna have to
channel you you know it's it's harder
because normally when I think of an idea
for a tweet yeah I go off and walk for
like
fifteen 20 minutes and and refine it
I'll do you yeah that's interesting
except last night related to drunken
wanna fire it away but anyway let's see
let's see how we get alright um no one
I'm not an improviser
I don't worry that's fine number one are
all cats feminists aha cats feminists
she would suggest that feminism is the
natural state and therefore all animals
are essentially feminists she also
believes that all animals are
essentially vegan but that they are
socialized into believing that they
should eat meat by our example that's
what that's what she thinks but there's
a line in the book where she talks about
her her vegan cat and she says yeah man
she does chase birds around the garden
but I think she must assume they're some
kind of flying vegetable or something
and is that thing about she just
projects projects her own RI ideas onto
everyone else but yeah yeah cats because
feminism is a natural state cool yes and
speaking of vegetables which is the most
oppressive vegetable I'm gonna take
better nut squash why I don't know I
said I think cause yet really yeah
because of that sort of French sounding
G which is how it's spelt in bourgeois
actually thinking about it it's the
aubergine because of the emoji
absolutely there we go which is used to
represent the phallus we've we've we've
answered yeah male dogs yeah sniff the
butts of males and females equally right
but only have sex with females
does this make dogs prejudiced good
question that's not altogether true that
was it sometimes with other boys yeah
and there are their own there are gay
dogs what about the ones that done they
should be killed
yeah fine well actually most dogs of
polyamorous thinking about it they have
made up they have multiple partners so
might work they're pretty damn won't
care I don't know so would you like I
improvise hey we've got it we've nailed
it now go hey work worked up the
vegetable and we've got cats and dogs
that's really big three all right that
is the big three is it so moving
forwards now we are in the midst of
Edinburgh Fringe yeah you've got the
italia live show how's that been going
I love it I love it it's so much fun we
are dividing audiences which is exactly
what it should be
how many is have you had many people
walk out yeah the gay guy I mean I
haven't been here for a lot of the shows
but Alice tells me every night updates
me every now and then there's there's a
moment where people walk out and what's
been interesting though is what people
walk out of enema shows all the time
remember right because they've got to
get to other shows and things so you can
never be sure you can't assume they're
offended it's always after the same
jokes though well Alice has had a couple
of examples where people have been
explicit about why they're leaving now
that really happens okay yeah um and
there was one the other night she said
the person on the front row just said
I'm sorry I just can't I can't do this
and walked out and I think like look I'm
sympathetic with anyone who is offended
by it or upset and I would also support
their right to leave I can be offended
by stuff in my own my views I'll just
leave and I'm not gonna stop whinging
about snowflakes and all this sort of
stuff like we all get offended by stuff
and we all know what upsets us and and
sometimes it's best not to expose
yourself to that but everyone's
different tolerances yeah yeah exactly
um but you know it the purpose of satire
is to annoy people as well as to
entertain some other you know you you
you can't it can't be it's not being
done right if everyone loves what you're
doing or indeed if everyone hates what
you're doing or you want to be slaying
people that's exactly what was that a
name when you were writing the
wonder-percent
yeah yeah I mean I I knew full well that
it would annoy people
I wanted it to they have bought tickets
though we give us a lot of people in a
number don't know what they're seeing
yeah that's that's the problem like the
problem there you've got two good Street
piers like the street P ours are so
effective like the airings guys on and
then unbelievable at their job miss on
the other hand I sort of want people to
know what it is because I want people to
enjoy I don't want people not tuned I
don't want to be able to go to a show
they're not going to enjoy I think the
tweets are more designed to annoy the
general public you know people who
happen to pond them and don't know who
she is that's funny to me but yeah I
think if you've invested money in a show
I'd like you to enjoy it for sure so I
do started I have said to the Flies can
you just be honest about what this is
like you know if people are thinking
they're going to see like a stand-up
show friends he's not a stand-up show
it's more like a play yeah if people
think that they're going to see you know
and feminist thing I mean it's obviously
mocking contemporary feminism you know
I'd rather people just knew and didn't
yeah got their money's worth
yeah I think so but we're challenged for
it so you know you've you've made a
Twitter account you've done all of this
stuff and now there is a living
breathing one-hour manifestation of a
Twitter account
yes onstage in front of you at the
Edinburgh Fringe for like what 29 39
yeah 20 25 shows yeah whoa what does
that does that feel I just feel like
this is the most 21st century thing
that's about it's yeah it's not one is
there and I certainly didn't expect it
to happen I certainly didn't I didn't
even know I was gonna write a book when
I started this yeah it wasn't that at
all yeah it's an odd feeling and also
because I know her so well yes and then
you see this sort of version of it in
the flesh my friend has it changed the
way that you think about her having seen
it manifest sort of you know I I don't
think it has because during the
rehearsal process what we were doing is
trying to get Alice's characterization
as close as possible to what is in my
head of course it's not entirely
possible and of course an actor will
always bring their own interpretation to
the role so but there's still this this
creature in my head who is a living
breathing thing who isn't quite what's
on stage isn't quite because you know
that's a combination of my writing
analysis interpretation it's something I
mean my friends are a bit worried about
me sometimes I suck I do talk about her
in the third person I do if she's in the
room I sort of do like your imaginary
friend it's not quite like that because
I'm very self-aware about it but what I
mean is I have a separate phone for her
for style okay the larger because
Twitter will ban you if you know you
don't want the same phone for both your
accounts because if she gets banned I
would get banned as well I got you
Twitter make you behave like a drug
dealer base of it you know and so
someone said to me that the very can you
tweet this from to town or can you
retweet this from sometimes like I
haven't got a phone with me sheesh you
know it's at home and I just said it and
she's saying this is worrying you know
she said as a real thing but it's not a
psycho I know so now I'm fully 100%
self-aware but cool but it helps to
think of her as because I start to think
about the way she would respond to
things which isn't obviously the way
that I would respond because it got
easier over time hmm yeah I mean I think
when I first started it so because I had
to delete
I think the tweets already there from I
went through a period about deleting
everything beyond seven deadlies because
people kept mass reporting the tweets
and that's how they do it to get you
boundary and now I got allow enough time
for them to accumulate exactly I don't
do that anymore just because I sort of
don't care if I get banned at this point
I think that's it to the stage now as
well were you you've been mentioned on
the Joe Rogan show like the the absolute
pinnacles okay I'm fine with the ban
I'm you know I I can do more the
characters out there now I can I can
write articles I can write shows I can
do whatever with it I don't need the
Twitter account really by enjoy it just
I still I'm still going to do it I still
enjoy it
but the early tweets were not as I think
they were just quite direct and they're
you know because there's two types of
tweets that she does there's the the
joke twin it's where she tried to expose
the inherent contradiction of the work
way of thinking and then there's the
bait tweets where she says something so
outrageous she wants people to restate
it seriously and those are normally the
right wing is the the Trump voters and
people who take it seriously and get
angry you know so this is the two types
of tweets and then and I often get
accused of well that's not that's not
even a joke that's just and I was like
yeah I'm baiting someone there yeah you
know and you know when she says that you
know intersectionality should be
eliminated and stuff like that you know
and she says future generations will
thank us if we do that you know that a
lot of the people do get angry and it
exposes something about their anger as
well yeah you know so I like having to
get both sides to be honest that's the
point
it must be a fun playground to be able
to have that so what do you think well
if you got any idea what you think's
next for to turn I don't know get the
fringe out the way
don't don't forget your lines and new
jokes and stuff for your show yeah don't
need to love you bud
that would be bad yeah I mean it's
actually the standard shambling next
week is like a version of the show i
toured at the start of the year and so
it should be alright i've got two days
just to rehearse they'll be fine um I
hope what next I don't know I don't like
doing the same thing for a long time so
I tend to try and move on
I'm considering writing a book about
politics at the moment which I've been
speak to my agent about so I might do
that it would be a serious book I mean I
I like the idea I've approached this
sort of woke movement from the satirical
side now I quite like to try it from the
polemical is it has it enhanced your
understanding of politics like in a
serious level playing around and
swimming in these sort of waters yeah
yeah what I mean first start I mean I've
come from that background I've always
written about politics and I've always
owned and I've come from a kind of woke
back I know a lot of work people so I've
sort of come from that that tradition
and that you know but yeah it always
informs me to talk to people who
disagree with me it always you know I I
that's what's so frustrating about so
many of these people's they won't talk
they won't debate they'll just walk away
they won't have their conversation where
it's actually I've got you know we've
all got a lot to learn from each other
and even people who say things that I
just hugely disagree with it's great to
hear what they've got to say it's also
been really useful to see the way that
people perceive me so you know I'm often
told things that they I think which I
don't think but that tells me that maybe
I'm not being quite clear enough in in
how I express my yes you know yes one of
the big things I get all the time is a
oh you always go on about how you can't
say anything anymore right I've never
said that I don't think it and I've
never said it I can say whatever I damn
well please and I do the point I'm
making is that in the current climate
that we live in if I was still a teacher
for instance I wouldn't be tweeting the
way I am now because I'd be fired right
very good so I think what is - I am in a
privileged position cuz I'm a comedian
and I can say whatever I want and I can
get away with it but I know that if I
were to go back to teaching now I can
never get a teaching job anymore let's
do it a cursory Google search and I'm
over right I mean when I was a teacher I
had parents complaining because they'd
googled me and read some of my jokes
online and they complained to the head
so it was already getting a bit yeah so
um so it isn't that I'm saying that we
can't say anything anymore what I'm
saying is most people who are in normal
jobs not fake jobs like what I do right
normal that they feel under pressure to
not joke with their workmates they feel
like they have to restrict their jokes
to encrypted whatsapp conversations
because if they are
heard and misunderstood were taken at
face value which is a common thing
people do with comedy now then they're
going to lose their jobs that is a
dangerous climate to be in we had it
with Bridget's article people are afraid
to express opinions online people who
email me saying I like your stuff but
I'm not going to say it public leader so
we are living in indisputably
in a culture where people are self
censoring routinely now out of fear of
either what what your peers will say or
the what the people on social media are
going to do to you because remember
their tactic is often to try and stop
your livelihood you know go after to go
to your employer complaint your employer
didn't really pass it up the chain until
you find a weak link all people are
afraid of the state you know in the UK
we have a horrible situation where we
have we have hate speech laws that have
led to people being imprisoned for jokes
they've written on Facebook actual jail
time right constant comes something
kisses says that in all of Russia every
person that was jailed honestly last
year because of jokes they met on social
media 400 the UK 3000 he's talking about
arrests rats not no jail for Josas very
rare but it has happened all they should
never happen by the way but it has
happened yeah but yet arrests
investigations it's over 3,000 in this
country and 400 in Russia that tells you
an awful lot hate speech laws should be
abolished absolutely clearly people
should be entitled to express hateful
views if they want to that's not to say
I support those papal views I absolutely
don't but what it you've got to think on
balance what is better here right I'd
love to live in a society where everyone
was nice to each other and no one said
these horrible ghastly things right I'd
love that that's not the real world
there are some awful people out there
who say some horrible things but is the
solution to that to give the state power
to lock people away if they don't agree
with what they say because that's where
we are
you've got to think about it in balance
what's the bigger picture I'd rather
live in a free society or I'm gonna hear
some idiot on a street corner shouting
about how I should go to hell because
I'm gay I'd rather hear that right then
have a situation where the government
can say well this is no longer
acceptable so now we're going to
investigate and arrest you for that
which is what's happening you know the
guy got investigated in homicide for
retweeting a poem about trans issues
right got it got investigated the the
police phoned him up and said we've got
to check your thing
right and that should never happen but
it's happening as a matter of routine
and we know this because when people
complain to the police about it they
said but this is just common across the
country if you go on the government's
hate crime legislation website it will
talk about non crime hate incidents that
are logged as part of the hate crime
statistics so when you when you hear
about these hate crime statistics you've
got to remember that a lot of them are
people finding the police saying someone
someone called me gay and I'm upset
about it and that gets logged no inch no
investigation needed it's logged because
if that person perceives that it was
homophobic that's it it's really
worrying and it is it's not
authoritarian in the way that they you
know fascist Italy was authoritarian but
it is a kind of creeping
authoritarianism and it has an
authoritarian aspect to it that needs to
be resisted and we shouldn't be
complacent about this stuff the problem
is no one wants to address it you're
very right but you are very right indeed
moving forward last thing what what are
the two most likely roots that you can
see us going down in the over the sort
of next couple of years in terms of in
terms of how the discourse is going to
mature okay so I've been asked this
question before the truth is I don't
know obviously because I'm not
clairvoyant but I do think we are
reaching a kind of tipping point right
well you've got so the work activists
are the minority and that's the
consolation if you'll take they just a
very loud one it's not just loud they
have power and that's what's dangerous
about them I mean they're mostly
bourgeois they're mostly privately
educated so they tend to occupy those
roles in society where they are
opinion-forming you know would they they
they are overly dominate the law a
journalism the media the arts all of
these sorts of areas universities
certainly so you end up in a situation
where they are dictating the sort of
common discourse right if the proper but
the problem is there are not minority
for them this is their problem there are
minority and people are buying it and
the more they push it the more people
push back so you know I mean I hate the
idea of this
seeing Millennials or the millennial
generation most Millennials think this
is [ __ ]
right it's it is the minority in
particularly student activists the type
of kids who end up in street in politics
they tend to be you know quite
narcissistic the quite so they're not
they're not representative of the
student body but everyone else is they
just want to get drunk enough fun of
that they'll go along with it like okay
we won't applaud we'll do jazz hands
instead if that you know that makes you
happy we'll just do it for an easy bike
of course right but it's not the norm
and then you know damn people grow up of
course and they go beyond that what
worries what worries me I mean I
personally I blame my generation I think
it's Generation X that fostered this
stuff and caused this stuff by indulging
it but so what will happen I think is
and particularly our Asians there I mean
the Millennials are getting old now
right they're past it now I mean this is
a nightly so you gotta be born after 96
I'm only just not a millennial people
people forget it's like the the
Millennial Generation is it's had it
today I mean all the statistics seems to
suggest that generations ed are pushing
way back against this stuff they've got
no time for it you don't even get that
you know I think that's what's going to
happen so and maybe they're sensing
their power is slipping and that's why
they're getting more and more aggressive
yeah that's what people do when they
when they're thrown when their power
base is threatened they start getting
these shrieking even louder yeah and so
they won't go down easy but they'll
never win because they just don't have
the numbers that and and this stuff is
totally unpersuasive so is the is the
main but a four year longer term that
this causes the backlash on the right
well that is a fair yeah and that's why
that's why we have to react a Swope
movement down as quickly as possible
because that's a genuine fear that that
could happen yeah I think I think how we
got I don't I don't know the truth is I
don't know maybe they will dominate and
and who knows I mean that would be
terrible to call you just a little off
all day yeah but I like to think that
most people are sick of it most people
are gonna gonna fight back against it
and things will change for the better
but that's me because I'm an optimist
that's why I think will happen thank you
and thank you so much for coming up I've
really enjoyed it the elephant show by
the time this goes up we'll have seen
whether or not you've you've had any
catastrophes on stage but I'm no no I
mean yeah we were worried with
media's gonna come along and throw
milkshakes or anything nothing like
that's how perfectly great well I'm
gonna bring your milk shipping and bring
it to drink to your show on Tuesday yeah
actually well throw it because actually
that'd be good publicity don't make
great publicity but I also don't we all
stood on Twitter by - Tanya McGrath oh
no 400,000 Nets followers or whatever it
is links to everything that we've spoken
about today including the articles
Andrews Twitter - Tanya's Twitter
everything else will be in the show
notes below if you've enjoyed the
episode please give us a like gives a
shirt definitely give to Tanya and
Andrew follow they're absolutely
fantastic I really appreciate you coming
to see me man no thanks a lot really
enjoyed it it's been great
[Music]
you